THE COMMITTEE IS LOOKING FOR
MEMBERS AS WELL AS AUTHORS SO IF
YOU'RE A. MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOU
JOINING US NOW IF YOU ARE
AUTHOR.
LIKEWISE
GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO.
TO THE RIGHT POLITICS WE'RE
GOING TO GET STARTED.
WE'RE STILL LOOKING FOR QUORUM
WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR. AND THERE
IS BUSINESS THAT WE CAN AT LEAST
TAKE UP AS A.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE.
OF THE WHOLE.
AND SO IF I COULD BEFORE I.
TWO WHY DON'T YOU JOIN US AND.
BUT I'M GOING TO JUST OF WHO
FEW HOUSEKEEPING MATTERS EVEN
THOUGH MISTER GALLAGHER IS NOT
HERE AT THE MOMENT.
WE WELCOME HIM.
TO THIS CITY.
AND AS IT COMES AND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK MISTER RODRIGUEZ FOR
SITTING AND FOR. DOCTOR EGGMAN
OF WHO IS NOT.
ABLE TO JOIN US TODAY WILL BE
ABSENT.
IT I WE HAVE A. AT LEAST UNDER
HOUSEKEEPING WE HAVE ONE.
CONSENT BY A. CONSENT ITEM THAT
WILL TAKE UP WHEN WE HAVE.
A QUORUM.
AND THERE ARE TWO ITEMS
BETTER PUT OVER TO APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH THAT'S ITEM FOR. AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY ONE WEBER.
AND I ITEM SIX AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY THREE QUIRK.
SO AS WE.
TURNED TO.
.
CHIU SUMMER CHIU.
YOU'RE HERE ON A. B. TWO ZERO
SIX EIGHT.
NOW GOT HER THANK YOU NOT QUE
WHOA. PLEASE SO YOU'RE FREE TO
BEGIN AS WE.
GATHER MEMBERS AND THE WAY TO
QUORUM BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING A PRESENTATION. TAKE YOU
VERY MUCH HAVE MISTER CHAIR TO
MEMBERS. AND ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
START BY A SECOND TO COMEY HE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH THE WHO WHO WAS
MY OFFICE.
AB TWENTY SIX CA ASK THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
TO EVALUATE THE IMPACT AND
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
SHOULD OR COULD HAVE THEIR OWN
GAS AND ELECTRIC. ELECTRICITY
RATE CATEGORY
INSTEAD OF BEING TREATED AS A
COMMERCIAL FACILITY.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS SCHOOL.
BUT AS FOR ALL THE STATE WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED AND YOU RATE
INCREASE.
UNLIKE OTHER ENTITIES OF SCHOOL
CANNOT EASILY RATES FEES
AND TAX TO CUT THE RECOVERED THE
INCREASING BECAUSE OF YOU YOU'D
INCREASING UTILITY COSTS.
SCHOOLS SPEND THE SAME AMOUNT
OF UTILITY COSTS ESTATE DO ON
BOOKS.
AND SUPPLIES
IT IS ONE OFF THE TOP FIVE
HIGHEST EXPENSE FOR SCHOOL.
AS AS A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER I KNOW FIRST HAND THE
FINANCIAL STRUGGLE DEAD TO
SCHOOL GO THROUGH. AND THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT THE DECK CAN
HELP TO DIRECT SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS.
AND ESPECIALLY OF SCHOOL IN MY
DISTRICT ARE SEEN LOWER AND
ROMAN GREAT.
AND WAS TO HIRE YOU UTILITY RATE
AND SOME HAVE BEEN FORCED TO LAY
ALL TEACHERS.
THIS BILL FOLLOWS A SIMILAR CPUC
DECISION LAST YEAR. THAT ASK
THIS SAN DIEGO ELECTRIC AND GAS
CORPORATION TO LOOK INTO
ESTABLISHING A SCHOOL ONLY RATE.
I LIKE TO A AND EXPAND THIS
CONSIDERATION STATEWIDE.
TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT IT MAKES
SENSE TO SUBJECT A DIFFERENT.
HOPEFULLY A LOWER RATE FOR
SCHOOL SO MORE MONEY CAN BE
DIRECTLY SPEND TOWER TO STUDENT.
I WAS ME HERE TODAY ARE A
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL. AND OF
THE FERREIRA FROM HIS SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION. AND NASTY
CHAIRS ON THE CALLER PHONE NO
SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION.
BUT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MET
EACH OTHER SUSPEND ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IT'S.
AT THE PLEASURE TO BE HERE IT'S
MAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WHICH ADDRESSES AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT ELEAZAR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
CONTENDING WITH.
WE ARE NOW.
CELEBRATING THIS YEAR WITH THE
COMPLETION OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA REACHING ITS
TARGET WE ARE NOW OFFICIALLY
BACK TO TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
FUNDING LEVELS.
WHICH YOU CAN IMAGINE I WASN'T
SUFFICIENT TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IS
NOT SUFFICIENT FOR OUR
EXPENDITURES NOW.
OR ONE OF THOSE EXPENDITURES
THE HAS BEEN INCREASING IS THE
COST OF ENERGY AND IT OUT IT
AFFECTS. IT AFFECTS SCHOOLS
DIFFERENTLY ACROSS THE STATE
BUT.
WE'VE SEEN INCENDIO GO COUNTY
WHERE SCHOOLS HAVE REALLY BEEN.
IMPACTED BY RATE SHOCK.
THESE INCREASES THAT THEY'VE
BEEN RECEIVING YEAR OVER YEAR
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS WHICH
WERE NOT RECEIVING ANY MORE HAVE
LARGELY BEEN CONSUMED.
BY ENERGY EXPENDITURE INCREASES
SO.
THIS ISSUE DIRECTLY AFFECTS
STUDENTS IN THEIR CLASSROOM AND
THE RESOURCES THAT WERE ABLE TO
DEVOTE TO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS.
I I DID WANT TO ADDRESS ONE
ISSUE.
THAT REALLY.
UNDERLIES WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT
IT'S ADDRESSED IN THE IN THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WE SUPPORT ALL
OF THEM BUT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE ISSUE OF.
PARCEL TAXES.
THE THE ENTIRE GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE REALLY OVER OVER
ENERGY IS.
BUILT ON THE NOTION THAT LOCAL
EDUCATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES CAN RAISE REVENUE AS
NEEDED WHEN THERE ARE INCREASES
IN OPERATIONAL EXPENDITURES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT JUST ISN'T
THE CASE WITH RESPECT TO.
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
THE ANALYSIS MAKES REFERENCE TO
THE FACT THAT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN SEEK
PARCEL TAXES.
BUT.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD SOME
CONTACTS TO SAY THAT THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT A FEASIBLE
ALTERNATIVE FOR MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
FEWER THAN TEN PERCENT OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PASS THE
PARCEL TAX.
THOUGH AND YOU REALLY SEE THOSE
FRANKLY IN THE WEALTHIER PARTS
OF THE STATE.
PARCEL TAXES ACCOUNT FOR LESS
THAN ONE PERCENT OF ALL OF THE
EDUCATION FUNDING IN THE STATE
SO JUST FOR CONTEXT WE THOUGHT
THAT THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
NOT THAT WE HAVEN'T. EXHAUSTED
OUR OUR LOCAL OPTIONS IT'S THAT
WE REALLY HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO
TURN SO I WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND BEFORE WE HEAR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. AND SO I'M GONNA ASK OF
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
ESTABLISHED CORE.
HOLDEN.
HERE PATTERSON HERE.
BURKE.
GEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
RODRIGUEZ THEIR.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK.
REYES.
SANTIAGO.
TING.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON BUT CHAIRMAN
HOLDEN IN MEMBERS I'M ANA
FERREIRA ON BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION WHERE AN
ORGANIZATION MADE UP OF SCHOOL A
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND THAT DOES INCLUDE
CHARTERS. AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION K. THROUGH TWELVE.
WHEN SUPPORT OF TWENTY SIXTY
EIGHT BECAUSE IT RECOGNIZES THE
UNIQUE NATURE AND ENERGY LOAD.
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE OFTEN AS
YOU'VE HEARD ONE OF THE TOP
THREE MOST COSTLY ITEMS. IN A
SCHOOL DISTRICTS DISCRETIONARY
BUDGET.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SPEND ABOUT AS
MUCH ON ELECTRICITY. AS THEY DO
ON BOOKS AND SUPPLIES.
WE APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS SINCE
THE MTA POINTING OUT THAT RATES
ARE INCREASING FOR ALL
CUSTOMERS.
BUT THE UNIQUENESS FOR SCHOOLS
IS THAT IN THE FACE OF THESE
INCREASES.
HOW THEY'RE ABLE TO RESPOND FUND
THEY CANNOT CHANGE THE WAY THAT
THEY DO BUSINESS?
IN RESPONSE
EDUCATING OUR STUDENTS IS NOT
LIKE MANUFACTURING WIDGETS.
WE CANNOT. THEY CAN'T BE MOVED
TO THE GRAVEYARD SHIFT.
IN THE FACE OF AN INCREASE IN
RATES.
TWENTY SIX STATES SIMPLY ASKS
THAT THE PC TAKE ITS OWN
RECOMMENDATION.
A STUDY WHETHER SCHOOL RATE
WOULD MAKE SENSE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT AND ELEAZAR CONSISTENT
ENCYCLICAL ENERGY USAGE AND
VULNERABILITY TO REACT TO THESE
RATES.
SO THAT ELEAZAR MAY REVIVE.
MAY RECEIVE A SPECIAL RATE THAT
IS LOWER AND MOVES THEM FROM
THEIR CURRENT COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL RATE CLASS.
WHICH IS NOT APPROPRIATE GIVEN
THEIR MISSION TO EDUCATE K.
TWELVE STUDENTS.
REPUBLICAN MUNICIPAL UTILITY
RATES ARE NOT INCLUDED BECAUSE
THE RATES ARE TRADITIONALLY
LOWER. AND BECAUSE THE BILL IS
SIMPLY TAKING A RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE PC MADE IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND APPLYING
IT TO THE OTHER ELECTRICAL
UTILITIES THAT IT REGULATES.
FINALLY.
IT IS CORRECT THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE CHARTER OR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION ARE UNABLE
TO RAISE TAXES AND FEES AS
FINANCING MENTION.
IT.
BUT SO THEY MUST ADDRESS THESE
RATES IN THE GENERAL FUND.
THIS IS THE SAME GENERAL FUND
THAT PAYS TEACHERS FUNDS BOOKS
AND OTHER TOOLS FOR LEARNING. IT
IS ALSO WHY WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY ONE WEBER. I'M WHICH
IS GOING TO BE HEARD NEXT WEEK.
MENTIONED AND OTHER LEGISLATION
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT WOULD
BETTER ALLOW SCHOOLS TO WEIGH IN
ON I OWE YOU RATES THAT MAY
IMPACT THEM.
WITH REGARD TO PARCEL TAXES
WHICH MUST BE PUT TO THE VOTERS
SCHOOLS ARE NO WAY ABLE TO
PREDICT WHAT KIND OF OR HOW MUCH
OF A RATE INCREASE. THEY MIGHT
RECEIVE AND TIME TO PUT A VOTER.
CAMPAIGN TOGETHER OR ASK
DISTRICT VOTERS
TO VOTE FOR FUNDS TO PAY FOR
FUTURE RATE INCREASES.
POTENTIAL ELECTRICITY RATE
INCREASES.
SO IT IS FOR THOSE REASONS THAT
WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE AYE ON
TWENTY SIXTY A IT ALLOWS CPUC TO
EXAMINING CRAFT A RATE. THAT
WOULD TAKE THE UNIQUE NATURE AND
CONSISTENT USAGE.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THEM ASSEMBLY
ABSORB THESE RATES BY CUTTING
AND OTHER AREAS THAT AFFECT OUR
STUDENTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BUT WILL NOW TURN TO
THE AUDIENCE AND WILL RECEIVE
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE HERE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL NAME.
EARLY EDITION.
AND JUSTICE YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRISTEN BROWN OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS HERE IN SUPPORT URGING
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
FAIR BY JUST OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
A MARINE ON BECAUSE URKEL
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
IN TO DEAL WITH THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL SHOT CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE WERE PREVIOUSLY
AND OPPOSE POSITION BUT BASED ON
THE AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE AND
ESTABLISH LANGUAGE. I WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION DID WANT
TO MAKE ONE NOTE IF.
THE CHAIR WOULD INDULGE FOR A
MOMENT.
MANUFACTURERS DO NOT HAVE AN
EASY TIME DEALING WITH HIGH
ENERGY PRICES EITHER.
SO WE ARE VERY SYMPATHETIC TO
THE SCHOOLS IN THE POSITION THAT
THERE AND. I WE DON'T SIMPLY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PASS ON
TERMS OF HIGHER PRICES BECAUSE
RUN A GLOBALLY COMPETITIVE
MARKET SO. OTHER STATES OTHER
COUNTRIES WE COMPETE AGAINST
THEM THEIR ENERGY COSTS ARE
LOWER THAT MAKES US LESS
COMPETITIVE SO WE DO.
EMPATHIZE CREEK DEAL WITH THE
SCHOOLS AND LOOK FOR TO FIND
WAYS TO REDUCE ENERGY COSTS FOR
EVERYBODY.
MR CHAIRMAN PERSONAL ANY HUNTER
ON BEHALF OF PACIFICORP WERE A
SMALL UTILITY THAT SERVES THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE SETS
DEL NORTON' ASKEW COUNTY. WE DO
HAVE A FORMAL OPPOSE POSITION ON
THE BILL WE WILL REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS WE JUST NOTE THAT
WHEN YOU ONLY HAVE FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS. AND FORTY
PERCENT OF THE MARKARIAN
PERSONAL LITTLE WIGGLE ROOM.
PROVIDING A DISCOUNT
POTENTIALLY FOR SCHOOLS.
COULD IMPACT OTHER REPAIRS AND.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF THEM
DESPITE COSTS
THANK YOU.
SO I GUESS WE BLENDED INTO THE
OF THE.
PROPOSAL THAT WHILE THERE.
A IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL.
HEARING NONE ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
PERRANCE SEEING NONE. OF WILL
TURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR.
SOME ARRESTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHU THIS IS A
FEASIBILITY STUDY RIGHT.
SO THIS IS THE FIRST STEP TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE THEM CAN MOVE
FORWARD TO TRY TO HELP OUR
SCHOOLS BUT TRYING TO FIND A WAY
TO DO IT.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS UP SO WE CAN FIND THOSE
WAYS TO MAKE SURE THE MONEY
STAYS IN OUR SCHOOLS WITH THE
TEACHERS. AND TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEARCH TO WAIT.
.
APPRECIATE YOUR BEST THERE WE GO
WE NEED A. SO IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE BILL AS
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'VE ALSO TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
FOLLOWING THE SAYS. YOU PROCEED
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF GATHERING
INFORMATION.
VALIDATING DIRECTION.
THANKING ALRIGHT CLICK HERE
ROCOCO.
AB TWO SIX EIGHT. THE MOTION AS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. HOLDEN
BY.
HOLDEN I.
CORRECTION TWO ZERO SIX EIGHT
AB.
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE FOR
BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
CAN IT CUNNINGHAM AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND WHAT OVERSEE AYE MAYES
I AYE MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI.
REFUGEE AYE QUIRK.
REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TEAM.
SO.
THERE ELEVEN THEIR ELEVEN VOTES
IN FAVOR OF WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT ALL.
AND I THANK THANK YOU
SACRAMENTO.
AND WHAT AND AGAIN WE'RE.
WAITING FOR OTHER AUTHORS IF WE
CAN.
ENCOURAGE THEM TO COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE WILL BE PREPARED TO
REVIEW THEIR BILLS.
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE US IN
THE RACE BILL IT'S ON CONSENT
USER MOTION TO THE CONSENT HOUSE
OF OF.
LET ME JUST SAY IT'S AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTEEN.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
LOCAL.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN DO PASSED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND WATER CO I MAYES. MAYES AYE
MURATSUCHI. MURATSUCHI AYE
QUIRK.
REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TING.
OKAY WHETHER ELEVEN VOTES IN
FAVOR WILL LEAVE THE ROLL CALL
OPEN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
AND WE ARE LOOKING FOR A YOU ARE
CURRY.
BERMAN AND A MOAN
RIGHT.
WELCOME SO MEMBER.
WE HAVE YOU HERE FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY ONE.
YES THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AB TWENTY THIRTY ONE REQUIRES
THAT I CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE OFFICE OF
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATES WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TO ENSURE THAT
ADEQUATE MARKETING EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH ARE UNDERTAKEN TO
ENABLE SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT
CUSTOMERS TO FULLY PARTICIPATE
IN ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
EXISTING LAW PERMITS SURCHARGES
ON BILLS OF ELECTRICITY AND GAS
CUSTOMERS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF FUNDING
INVESTOR. OWNED UTILITY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
HELP CALIFORNIA BE MORE ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND COLLECTIVELY
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
SUCH REPAIR FUNDED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS FOR MORE
ENERGY EFFICIENT RETROFITS AND
PRACTICES BY MEANS OF FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES REBATES EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. EXPENDING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IN THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR IS CRUCIAL TO ACHIEVING
STATE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION TARGETS.
HOWEVER SMALL BUSINESSES DESPITE
INTO EXISTING THAT DESPITE PAIN
INTO EXISTING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS THREE ELECTRICITY AND
GAS RATES PARTICIPATE MINIMALLY
IN EXISTING ENERGY CONSERVATION
PRACTICES. OFTEN DUE TO THE LACK
OF AWARENESS AND LIMITED
RESOURCES.
STUDIES AND EXISTING I OWE YOU.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PLAN
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR GREATER
SMALL BUSINESSES PER
PARTICIPATION AND ENERGY
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS.
AB TWENTY THIRTY ONE SIX TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY ENSURING
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE A
GREATER AWARENESS. PUB AND
ACCESS TO EXISTING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PRACTICES
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AS SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY.
DAY YEAH HE'S THE IT WE RAN A
BIGGER AYE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
AND THE.
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE A
REPRESENTED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
GREEN BUSINESS NETWORK.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK.
THE NETWORK IS A NONPROFIT THAT
OVERSEES TWENTY SEVEN A GREEN
BUSINESS PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I AM WAS CREATE AN
STATURE PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO BUSINESSES TO
PREVENT OUR.
WILL REDUCE POLLUTION CONSERVE
RESOURCES AND SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
ALL WHILE SAVING BUSINESSES
MONEY.
AT THE PROGRAM TARGETS
EQUIVALENT UNDERSERVED ON CAP
SECTOR OF SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZED
BUSINESSES.
WHICH CONTRIBUTE CALIFORNIA'S
POOR AIR QUALITY AND AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LOS A BUT WE'RE
ALSO HERE TO BE POSITIVE
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
AT THERE WERE SEVERAL STATE
FUNDED CLEAN ENERGY IN GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE BUSINESS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
UP PETE FOR USING COMMERCIAL
TAXES AND OR FEES ON UTILITY
BILLS.
IT'S BEEN OUR EXPERIENCE THAT IT
IS DIFFICULT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES OR MICRO BUSINESSES
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
INCENTIVES AND REBATES. I THIS
IS BECAUSE OFTEN BUSINESSES OF
THIS SIZE YOU DON'T KNOW A OF
THE INCENTIVES THAT EXIST OR
EXISTING OUTREACH EFFORTS ARE
MOSTLY FOCUSED ON MEDIUM TO
LARGE BUSINESSES.
I AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE IS
A VERY STRONG IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IN ITS INTENDED
PURPOSE. IT WOULD REQUIRE THAT
P. YOU SEE WITH THE HELP OF
GOBIZ I TO ENSURE THAT ADEQUATE
OUT WHICH IS BEING DONE WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES TO WARN BETTER
PARTICIPATION. IN EXISTING
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ITEM.
YEAH.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
WE WILL PAUSE FOR SECOND SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY.
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
A LOOK AT ALL THAT HEARING GOING
ON.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO IS HERE
THAT.
.
IT'S LOOKING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
RIGHT.
OKAY WILL TURN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OR THE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR WHO IS RECEIVING A
STANDING OVATION AND ALL.
HEARING NONE
WE THANK YOU FOR.
VERY IMPORTANT BILL OUT REACHING
TO THE COMMUNITY IS ALWAYS A
GOOD THING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
CERTAINLY IT'S A WARNING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS IN THIS
WOULD BE. THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU.
DR.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE DO
PASS AS AMENDED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HOLDEN
AYE HOLDEN AYE.
PATTERSON. PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND WORKERS IN YEAH I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I QUIRK.
REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TEAM.
REGULATIONS YOU HAVE ELEVEN
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MEMBERS DATA OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
.
YET WE.
HERE.
WILL RESTRICT YOUR JOINT
YOURSELF. DAYS JOINT AUTHORED.
WE'RE JUST SO SO JUST FOR THE
RECORD.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY IS.
ASSURING COMMITTEE.
AND THERE'S NO VICE CHAIR AND
SO SHE'S
STOCK.
FOR THE MOMENT SO THAT WOULD BE.
.
SHARES OF.
OKAY IF MR GARCIA YOUR.
BECAUSE THE DOCTORS OKAY AND I
DON'T.
WE GOT THAT.
NOT THAT ALL PARTS OF
THE BILL.
BUT THAT STOP THAT'S FINE I'LL
GO.
OKAY.
AND THEN MISTER BERMAN IS ALSO
IN COMMITTEE
I MEAN.
BUT MISTER BERMAN WELCOME.
YEAH I'M.
WE APPRECIATE YOU I KNOW THIS
HAS BEEN A VERY A CHALLENGING
AFTERNOON IN TERMS OF MAKING
YOUR WAY AROUND TO VARIOUS
COMMITTEE DIDN'T YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND. AS THEY
ARE.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TO PRESENT A BIG TWENTY TO
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND LET ME JUST
PREFACE BY SAYING THAT.
NORMALLY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
YOU WILL HEAR DOCTOR QUIRK A
SPEAK VERY OFTEN.
BUT TODAY HAS LARGE IDEA SO WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SPEAK.
SO IF IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S QUIET
AND IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THAT HE'S
NOT ENGAGED.
I JUST CAN'T TALK
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
.
WELL MISTER COURT MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO TALK USED CLEARLY STILL
VERY FAST BECAUSE. I WAS JUST
PRESENTING FOR HIM.
AND.
GEO COMMITTEE AND I LEFT BEFORE
HE DID AND HE GOT HERE BEFORE I
DID.
SO I HAVE A LOT TO LEARN ABOUT
HOW TO GET AROUND THIS BUILDING
CLEARLY.
THINK DETERMINE HOLDEN AND AND.
HOLDEN AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS DESCRIBED
ON PAGE SIX OF THE ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY EIGHT
PRESERVES THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
SELF GENERATION BILL CREDIT. OR
REYES BCT PROGRAM.
WHICH ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND PUBLIC COLLEGES
TO GENERATE RENEWABLE ENERGY IN
ONE LOCATION AND HAVE ACCREDITED
AGAINST THE ELECTRICITY USE THAT
AND IN ANOTHER LOCATION.
FOR EXAMPLE A COUNTY COULD
LOCATE SOLAR PANELS OVER THE
PARKING LOT A PARK BUT YOU SEE
ELECTRICITY FOR A COUNTY JAIL.
AND THE CURRENT STATUTE WHICH AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY EIGHT DOES NOT
CHANGE
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES AT NO COST
SHIFTING TO OTHER RATEPAYERS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND PUBLIC
COLLEGE CAMPUSES HAVE INVESTED
IN RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS AND
RELY ON THE REYES BCT PROGRAM TO
MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS FEASIBLE.
RECENTLY THE STATE'S INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES HAVE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO TIME OF USE PERIODS
AND SEASONAL DEFINITIONS AND A
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS IN THE
AMOUNT CREDITED PER KILOWATT
HOUR. TO SOLAR CUSTOMERS LIKE
REYES BCT CUSTOMER.
THESE CHANGES RENDER MOST REST
BCT PROJECT ECONOMICALLY UNDER
WATER AND MAKE THE REYES BCT
PROGRAM EFFECTIVELY INOPERABLE.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT SIX
TO HOLD HARMLESS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THAT INVESTED IN RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECTS BASED ON TIME OF
USE RATES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE FOR DECADES.
I HAVE WITH ME SUSAN GOBER
MILLER WITH THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
AND OTHER AND OTHER WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
PERCY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU HERE
TODAY I'M DOCTOR SUSAN GILBERT
MILLER.
DIRECTOR OF SUSTAINABILITY FOR
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA AND I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU AN INSIGHT
INTO HOW. WE'VE BEEN AFFECTED.
IN TERMS OF THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
SELF GENERATION BILL CREDIT.
TRANSFER PROGRAM REDS BCT.
WHICH WAS AUTHORIZED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT.
THIS IS BEEN A REALLY VALUABLE
TOOL FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IT
ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO.
PUT RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS
ON.
AVAILABLE LAND.
IT'S ALLOWED US TO USE THE
TRANSFER BILL CREDITS.
TO PAY FOR OTHER GOVERNMENT
ELECTRICITY ACCOUNTS THAT
CURRENTLY ARE NOT SOLAR.
AND BY STATUTE AS YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD REQUIRES THAT THERE BE NO
COST SHIFTING TO OTHER UTILITY
CUSTOMERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN.
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA
AUTHORIZED FOR THERE TO BE SIX
SO RENEWABLE.
PROJECTS CONSTRUCTIONS IN
OPERATION OF SIX
SOLAR GENERATING SYSTEMS.
AND OF THOSE SIX SYSTEMS FIVE OF
THEM RELIED ON THE REDS BCT.
PROGRAM.
AT THE TIME OF CONSTRUCTION.
OUR FIVE GROWTH BCT PROJECTS
WERE PROJECTED.
TO RESULT IN A REDUCTION OF OUR
ELECTRICITY COSTS OF BY
APPROXIMATELY FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND THAT WAS OVER THE TWENTY
FIVE YEAR LIFE TERM OF THOSE
PROJECTS.
THE PROJECTS WERE FINANCED USING
CLEAN RENEWABLE ENERGY BONDS
WHICH IS THAT MEANS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WERE ABLE TO FINANCE
THESE RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS.
RECENTLY.
THE STATE'S UTILITIES HAVE.
AS YOU'VE HEARD PROPOSED TO MAKE
CHANGES IN THE TIME OF USE
PERIODS AND THE SEASONAL
DEFINITIONS FOR THE REST OF THE
FEW KEY PROJECTS.
THE FOR THEIR TARIFFS.
THESE CHANGES WILL SEVERELY
IMPACT THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF
OUR REYES BCT PROJECTS.
ALTHOUGH THE UTILITY TARIFFS ARE
BY THEIR VERY NATURE VARIABLE.
AT THE
TIME WHEN WE WERE DEVELOPING THE
SOLAR PROJECTS THE MAGNITUDE OF
THIS KIND A CHANGE IN TERMS OF
TIME OF USE AND FOR THE SEASON
DEFINITION. WITH. UNFORESEEABLE.
SO EVEN WITH TEN YEARS WORTH OF
GRANDFATHERING AND OF THE TIME
OF USE AND THE SEASONS.
WHICH I HAVE BEEN PROVIDED BY
THE CPUC.
THE COUNTIES COST SAVINGS ON THE
REDS BCT PROJECTS WILL SHRINK SO
SIGNIFICANTLY THAT THE PROJECTED
SAVINGS THAT WE HAD.
DETERMINED WILL IT BASICALLY
EVAPORATE.
THIS
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE DIRECTLY
AFFECTS THE COUNTY'S BUDGET AND
THEREFORE AFFECTS OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL PUBLIC
SERVICES TO OUR COMMUNITY.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY EIGHT.
THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU.
WILL SIMPLY FREEZE THE TIME OF
USE PERIODS AND THE SEASONAL
DEFINITIONS FOR REDS BCT
PROJECTS.
THIS ESSENTIALLY WILL DO THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF HARM TO OURS AND
THE REDS BCT PROJECTS OF OTHERS.
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY
OF THESE PROJECTS.
AND CONTINUE TO BE A PART OF THE
STATE'S VERY CRITICAL EFFORTS
TO BE ABLE TO GREEN OUR ELECTRIC
GRID.
SUPPORT GREEN JOBS REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND. BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR ME JUST PAUSE FOR
A SECOND.
.
SANTIAGO YOU'RE CATCHING MY EYE
WAS THERE.
ONE OF THE MOVE APPROPRIATE.
YOU CAN MOVE ANALYSIS LIKE. WHO
THE BILL? YEAH.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DELETING
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL OUR
MEMBERS OTHER SOLAR DEVELOPERS
THAT GO UP TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DEVELOP THESE
PROJECTS.
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT AND
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YEAR OTHER OTHERS HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR THE BILL.
ARE THERE ANY.
WITNESSES OR INDIVIDUALS OF
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
PERFECT TO.
YOU'RE GOOD.
FIND UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
AND WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL ALTHOUGH WE UNDERSTAND
THE SITUATION. ON THAT THE
COMMUNITIES HAVE.
ARTICULATED AND THEIR DESIRE TO
RETAIN A CERTAIN LEVEL OF BILL
CREDITS FOR BEHIND THE METER
SOLAR SYSTEMS ON THE TREATMENT
THAT'S PROVIDED IN THIS BILL IS
ON PRECEDENT IT. IT ESSENTIALLY
WOULD LOCK IN FOR APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS TIME OF USE
PERIODS THAT WERE IN A FACT
AS OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN BOTH FOR
ANY. EXISTING REDS BCT CUSTOMER
AND FOR ANY NEW RECIPE CITY
CUSTOMER.
TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THAT'S
DIFFERENT I'M FROM THE T. O. U.
PERIODS THAT WILL BE ESTABLISHED
VERY SOON.
I'M PRIOR TO JANUARY TWENTY ONE
AT JANUARY ONE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE PEAK PERIOD YOU OFFER PGD
CUSTOMERS WAS TWELVE SIX PM.
THAT WAS THE HIGHEST VALUE
PERIOD FOR GENERATING
ELECTRICITY.
THAT PERIOD IS CHANGING IT WILL
GO TO SOMETIME BETWEEN FOUR AND
NINE PM THAT WILL BE THE NEW
PEAK. AND THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HEARD MUCH TESTIMONY ABOUT THE
SHIFTING PEAK IN THE RESULT OF
NOT LOAD ON THE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER A REYES BCT CUSTOMER
UNDER THIS BILL WOULD CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE PREMIUM VALUE FOR
PRODUCTION OCCURRING BETWEEN
TWELVE AND SIX PM. UP UNTIL
TWENTY FORTY FOUR.
I NOT ONLY AGAIN EXISTING
CUSTOMERS BUT A NEW CUSTOMER
THAT SIGNS UP IN TEN YEARS FROM
NOW WOULD STILL GET. THE DEAL
YOU PERIOD THAT WAS IN EFFECT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
MAKES SENSE ON IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT COST SHIFT IT DOES
NOT SATISFY THE STANDARD OF
INDIFFERENCE THAT IS ARTICULATED
IN THE ANALYSIS. AN EXISTING LAW
THEREFORE WE THINK THAT IT DOES
NOT STAND UP TO ANY SCRUTINY.
IN ADDITION AND THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THE GENERATION RATE
INCREASE BY THREE PERCENT PER
YEAR FOR EVER IS INCONSISTENT
WITH THE DIRECTION RATES ARE
NECESSARILY GOING GIVEN THE
CHANGING TIME OF USE PERIODS. IT
SETS UP A VERY SIGNIFICANT
SUBSIDY STREAM INTO THE FUTURE
AND IT IS IN TOTAL CONTRAST TO
THE EVOLUTION OF NET METERING
POLICY. AT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION
SO WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
POLICY IS CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING PRACTICE WITH WHAT WE
EXPECT TO BE THE FUTURE
EVOLUTION OF NET METERING. AND
IT REALLY I'M HANDCUFFS THE P.
YOU SEE FROM BEING ABLE TO
DEVELOP REASONABLE RATE DESIGN
THAT BALANCES THE INTERESTS OF
THE CUSTOMERS WHO WOULD BE
BENEFITING FROM THIS PROGRAM.
AND THE REMAINING CUSTOMERS.
WHO WOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
COST OF THE PROGRAM?
THANK YOU.
OKAY AT CHERRY MEMBERS THE GOING
UP AND IT'S WITHIN YOUR GAS
ELECTRIC.
WHAT THINK THE STAFF AT THE
CONFERENCE OF ANALYSIS SOMEWHERE
HERE TO POSE AB TWO TWO SEVEN
EIGHT?
AYE WE BELIEVE THIS IS
LEGISLATIVE RIGHT MAKING AND AS
A CONSIDER A LOT OF FACTORS A
PARTICULAR SYSTEM BENEFITS.
GENERATION COSTS AND IMPACTS TO
OTHER CUSTOMERS A PARTICULAR
RESIDENTS.
.
AS WAS MENTIONED AT TIME OF USE
HAS BEEN A LONG ANTICIPATED
POLICY ON THE LEGISLATURE CPC
AND OTHERLOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
ENDORSED ON THIS NEW THAT PEAK
PERIOD THAT WE'VE SHIPPED TO.
AND THE BILL AS WAS MENTIONED
ALSO REVERTS BACK TO PREVIOUS
TIME FRAME WITH THE FULL
DEFINITION WHICH IS WHOLLY
COUNTERINTUITIVE TO. NOT ONLY.
ENCOURAGING ENERGY CONSERVATION
BUT ALSO A ONE EIGHTY HAVE FLED
FROM WHAT LEGISLATURE HAS
SUPPORTED.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT UNDER THIS
RATE STRUCTURE OF THE PRICES DO
NOT REFLECT THE ACTUAL VALUE OF
ENERGY PRODUCED OR CONSUMED AND
ULTIMATELY THIS WOULD HAVE.
AT A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON OUR
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS.
ANOTHER.
ISSUE I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION
IS THAT IT IGNORES.
.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHIFTING TO UP
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATION AND
AND WHICH IS INCREASINGLY
SERVING IN OUR AYE YOU CUSTOMERS
NOT TO MENTION THAT THESE
PROVIDERS ARE NOT MANDATED TO.
TO TO GO TO TIME OF USE.
BUT IT'S NOT FAIR FOR OTHER
CUSTOMERS AND WILL BE WHO WILL
BE STUCK PAYING THE BILL.
WHILE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
CHOOSING TO DEPART BUT POINTING
TO.
LOCK IN RATES FOR THE REMAINING
IT UP FACILITIES.
I'M SO WE JUST WANT TO ALSO
MENTION THAT.
YOU KNOW WERE ALL IN FAVOR FOR.
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
OTHERS MOVING TOWARDS RENEWABLE
ENERGY SOURCES AND SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC IS PROUD TO BE AT
FORTY FIVE PERCENT RENEWABLE
SOURCES.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
COMMITTEES ELEMENTS BUT.
WOULD HAVE TO SAY RESPECTFULLY
THAT COULD LEAD TO SPELLS
UNNECESSARY AND UNFAIR FOR ALL
CUSTOMERS TO RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION A VOTE. THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS RYAN PARINI WAS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON WOULD
LIKE TO APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
SUBMITTING OUR LETTER.
EARLIER HOWEVER WE'VE HAD.
A CONVERSATIONS WITH.
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND THEY
HAVE EXPRESSED THOSE CONCERNS.
THEY'RE ALIGNED WITH WHAT HAS
ALREADY PREVIOUSLY BEEN STATED
WE BELIEVE THAT IF THE MET.
AUTHOR IS TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS IT MAKES IT A BIT
MORE PALATABLE ALTHOUGH WE DO
ULTIMATELY BELIEVE IT WOULD
RESULT AKASHI HAVE.
THOSE BORING THE BILL.
IRRELEVANT SO WITH THAT WE ARE
REMAIN CONCERNED TAKE YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRED VENA
FLEMING'S ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY OUT WE
APOLOGIZE AS WELL FOR GETTING
EARLY AND LETTER IN LATE HOWEVER
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. WE
BELIEVE IT IS UNNECESSARY AND
IMPOSES A CAUTIOUS ON NON
PARTICIPATING CUSTOMERS THIS IS
BEEN VETTED AT THE P. YOU SEE
AND WE SHOULD ABIDE BY WHAT THE
P. YOU SEE HAS ORDERED IN THIS.
SETTLEMENT WITH FEET A LOCAL
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS AND OUT WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE NO BOAT THINK
YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHERS OF LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
I WILL TURN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS.
HEARING NONE.
MISTER BERMAN WE. KNOW THAT
THIS IS BEEN A A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL NOT ONLY FOR.
THE COMMUNITY THAT YOU
REPRESENT BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE THAT
CERTAINLY WE'RE LOOKING TO
BENEFIT BY IT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT. AS WAS STATED AT THE P.
YOU SEE THAT HAVE A HEARING ON
THIS MATTER AND HAS SORT OF LOOK
AT IT IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
SORT OF THE CORE PRINCIPLES OF
THE COMMITTEE IS OF NOT TO DO
LEGISLATIVE RATE PAYING. A RED
CENT RATE SETTING.
AND ALSO THE ISSUE OF COST
SHIFTING.
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK THAT
YOU YOU RECOGNIZE THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE IT AND WE. IN THE
SPIRIT OF WHICH THIS AMENDMENT
WAS MADE WAS TO.
FOR ALL INTENDED PURPOSES
GIVE YOU. ANOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE.
I WILL SAY THAT IT'S A HELL
MERRY.
OF FOR THE RECORD BUT I THINK
THAT.
.
YOU KNOW THERE IS THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS AND TO AT LEAST.
HAVE YOU AND YOUR SPONSORS HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SORT OF
PASSION.
ANNIE STRATEGIES ARE IDEAS THAT
WOULD NOT CAUSE THERE TO BE.
RATE SHIFTING.
WE
WILL LOOK TO THE P. UC TO
OPERATE WITHIN ITS.
STATED GUIDELINES SHOULD GET TO
THE PC AND THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO.
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS RATE SHIFTING. AND IF IT IS
THAT WOULD BE OUR RECOMMENDATION
THAT THEY NOT.
SUPPORT THIS.
EFFORT.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT AND I
APPRECIATE.
YOUR EFFORTS AND.
THE COMMITTEE THAT YOU
REPRESENT.
IT'S THE.
CHEERS.
RECOMMENDATION FOR A DO PASS AS
AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE
JUST ONE.
SAY THANK YOU BUT YOU'RE HOLDEN
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD IN THE TIME THAT YOU PUT IN.
OF BEEN VERY EDUCATIONAL AND
INFORMATIONAL FOR ME.
AND APPRECIATE THE CHANCE AT A
HELL MARRY AGAIN.
THE EXISTING REQUIRES THAT THE
CPC ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO COST
SHIFTING.
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO THAT.
AND AND APPRECIATE.
AND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
A REPUBLIC.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO SEVEN
EIGHT DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HOLDEN
ARE HOLDEN AYE. PATTERSON THOUGH
PATTERSON NO BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO.
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE MAYES.
MAYES KNOW MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE REYES.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TING.
OTHER SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILLS ON CALL AND WILL BE
VERY.
BROKEN AS MEMBERS.
RIGHT THERE WHERE THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
SURE.
OKAY LET'S.
LET'S TURN BACK TO THE.
AGENDA AND WE WILL LOOK TO MAKE
OUR WASTE OF ADD ONS FOR THOSE
MEMBERS WHO DO NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON ANY OF
THESE MEASURES.
SIXTY MINUTES TO.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT I'M
SORRY TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE CALLING
ABSENT MEMBERS CHEN.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I.
TING.
OKAY.
AB.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ROLE OPEN.
ARE WE WILL.
I NOW TURN TO.
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT.
OUR A GUARD CURRY THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA RENEWABLES PORTFOLIO
STANDARDS PROGRAM LOCAL.
PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC AND GAS
UTILITIES ELECTRICAL AND GAS
CORPORATION. AND WE KNOW THAT
STUCK IN COMMITTEE AND SO.
AMERICA'S HERE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AS YOU CAN SEE YOU ARE A TWO
WITNESSES ARE.
READY TO GO I WILL LET READ MY
STATEMENT FIRST AS THE TO AND UP
TO THE BILL. IN THE. INTERESTS
OF UP MISS AT YOUR CURRY
POSSIBLY WALKING IN A TOWARDS
THE TALENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION A SECOND DOWN.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TO AWAIT WHICH WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET.
IT'S CLIMATE CHANGE GOLD AN
ENERGY NEEDS BY INSURING THE
YOUS AND PROCUREMENT OF SPECIFIC
RENEWABLE. RESOURCES.
FIRST ELECTED THANK ARE GOING
AUTHOR MISS AT YOUR CURRY FOR
PARTNERING ON THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT.
AB THIRTY TO THE LANDMARK
CLIMATE BILL PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX DIRECTED THE STATE
TO MAXIMIZE BENEFITS.
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS AND TO
CONSIDER OVERALL SOCIAL BENEFITS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
IMPROVEMENTS IN AIR QUALITY.
DIVERSIFICATION OF ENERGY
SOURCES AND OTHER BENEFITS TO
THE ECONOMY THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AB ONE NINETY SEVEN.
A PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND STEEN
FURTHER DIRECTED THE STATE TO
ENSURE MISSION REDUCTIONS WERE
HAPPENING IN OVER BURDEN
COMMUNITIES.
THIS MEANS WE MUST DO MORE THAN
JUST SET STATEWIDE STANDARDS.
BUT DO SO IN A NOR WANTS WAY TO
INSURE CHO BENEFITS ARE REALIZED
IN REGIONS OF OUR STATE. THAT
ARE IN MOST NEED OF THOSE
BENEFITS.
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT IS A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN
FINALLY START MAKING THOSE
PROMISES A REALITY.
FOR IMPERIAL COUNTY THIS BILL IS
ABOUT MORE THAN JUST ENERGY IT
IS ABOUT THE INTERSECTION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. AND JOB
CREATION
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE HUNDREDS OF GOOD PAINT
JOBS ANY PART OF THE STATE THAT
SUFFERS FROM STUBBORNLY HIGH.
UNEMPLOYMENT WHILE ADDRESSING
SOME OF OUR GREATEST AIR QUALITY
AND ECOLOGICAL THREATS AT THE
SALTON SEA.
TODAY THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN A
PILL IS SIXTEEN PERCENT.
THE SECOND HIGHEST IN THE STATE
NEXT TO COLUSA COUNTY WHICH IS
TWENTY PERCENT.
TO PUT THINGS INTO PERSPECTIVE A
FEW YEARS AGO IMPAIR COUNTY HAD
THE HIGHEST ON THE POINT COUNTY.
IN THE NATION AT OVER TWENTY
SEVEN PERCENT. ALMOST A THIRD OF
THE POPULATION.
LONG TERM GILT THERMAL ENERGY IS
SIGNIFICANT AS A PRODUCES NEARLY
FIVE TIMES THE NUMBER OF JOBS
THAT INTERMITTENT RESOURCES SUCH
AS SOLAR AND WIND.
WITH THE RETIREMENT OF NUCLEAR
RESOURCES SUCH IS DOUBLE CANYON
AND SEVERAL FREE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A DISTINCT OPPORTUNITY
TO REPLACE THOSE BASELOAD
RESOURCES WITH GEOTHERMAL
ENERGY.
SALTON SEA KNOWN PUPIL MORE
RESOURCE AREA HAS UP TO TWO
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF UNTAPPED
POTENTIAL.
I RESOURCES UNFORTUNATELY THIS
AREA REMAINS UNDER DEVELOPED
MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR
STAKEHOLDERS TO MONETIZE THIS
RENEWABLE ENERGY. POTENTIAL.
THIS IS WHY AB TWENTY TOY IS
IMPORTANT TO US AS IT ENJOYS A
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE IMPAIR
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
NUMEROUS DEVELOPERS INCLUDING OR
MET CAL ENERGY ENERGY SOURCE
CONTROLLED THAT MORE RESOURCES
AND YOU'LL GEN COMPANY TO NAME A
FEW.
ADDITIONALLY WE NEED TO SEEK A
BALANCED APPROACH TO RENEWABLE
ENERGY MINDFUL OF HOW MUCH
CARBON EACH SECTOR ADMITS.
FRANKLY WE CAN DO MORE AS A
STATE TO MANAGE OUR RESOURCES
INCLUDING WATERSHEDS TO ALLOW
FOR THE BALANCED APPROACH TO
RENEWABLES INCLUDING GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES.
APPRECIATE AT THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THE ANALYSIS DEDICATED TO THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCESS WHICH CURRENTLY. IS
UNDERWAY AT THE PC.
I SUPPORT THAT PROCESS IN FACT I
VOTED FOR THAT BILL THE CREATED.
THE REASON WE NEED THIS BILL IS
NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T TRUST THE I
RP.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PROVIDE MARK
UNCERTAINTY TO DEVELOPERS NOW SO
THAT THEY HAVE THE CONFIDENCE.
TO BUT PROVIDE MARKET CERTAINTY
TO DEVELOPERS SAID THEY HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE TO RISK VALUABLE
INVESTMENTS IN DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION COSTS TO BUILD
THESE FACILITIES NOW.
UNFORTUNATELY APPEAL COUNTY DOES
NOT HAVE THE LUXURY.
AND TIME TO WAIT FOR THE I RP.
THE STATE HAS KICK STARTED ITS
INVESTMENT IN MITIGATION
PROJECTS NECESSARY FOR THE
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
NOT ONLY FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
IMMEDIATELY SURROUNDING THE SEA
BUT THE ENTIRE STATE.
THE BILL WILL HELP MOVE THE MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES FORWARD.
FOR THE NEXT YEAR NOT TEN YEARS
FROM NOW
BUT NOW.
IN CLOSING LET'S NOT FORGET
MEMBERS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
UNCONDITIONALLY LIABLE FOR
MITIGATING THE IMPACTS OF THE
QUANTIFICATION SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT.
THE LARGEST RURAL TO URBAN WATER
TRANSFER IN THE UNITED STATES.
AGREEMENT IS CAUSING THE SALTON
SEA TO COLLAPSE EXPOSING
HUNDREDS OF MILES OF SHORELINE
DID THAT ARE STRONG WINDS.
DEVELOPING THESE FACILITIES WILL
NOT ONLY HELP COVER SOME OF THE
EXPOS PLAYA BUT ALSO GENERATE
THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO HELP THE
STATE MEET.
LEGAL OBLIGATION TO THIS REGION.
ON EL READ MRS AT YOUR CURRY
STATEMENT.
WELL FOR THE RECORD.
AB TWENTY TO AVOID WILL PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY COURSE.
CORRECTION FOR THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD PROGRAM.
AS WE MOVE TO INCREASE YOUR
NOBLE PROCUREMENT TOWARDS FIFTY
PERCENT AND BEYOND. ARE
RENEWABLES ARE OUT OF BALANCE
AND LESS DIVERSE.
THERE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH OF WIND AND ESPECIALLY
SOLAR WHICH ARE VALUABLE BUT
INTERMITTENT RESOURCES.
THE SAME TIME BIO ENERGY AND
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES HAVE NOT
GROWN.
MANY FACILITIES HAVE CLOSED AND
MANY MORE WILL COME OFF LINE
WITHOUT BEING WE COUNTRY THAT.
IN THE COMING YEARS.
BEFORE WE REACH THE FIFTY
PERCENT ARE PS MARK WE ARE NOT
WE ARE ON TRACK TO LOSE VALUABLE
RESOURCES.
THE STATE HAS SIGNIFICANT
INTEREST IN PRESERVING.
THESE RESOURCES AVAILABLE NOT
ONLY TO SMOOTH GREAT IMBALANCES
BETWEEN SUPPLY AND DEMAND. BUT
ALSO TO PROVIDE ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS TO
STATE.
IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE A LARGE
GEOTHERMAL FACILITY THAT HAS
PROVIDED HIGH WAGE JOBS FOR
DECADES
MY CONSTITUENTS CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE THOSE JOBS.
WE ALSO CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE
THE GREAT BENEFITS THE GUY JUST
PROVIDE TO CALIFORNIA. THE
RELIABLE RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT
KEEPS THE LIGHTS ON AT NIGHT
WHEN THE SUN IS NOT SHYING.
THAT FACILITY ALSO TREATS
WASTEWATER AND HAS HELPED CLEAN
UP WILD RIVERS LIKE THE RUSSIAN
RIVER.
RIVERS THAT FACE INCREASING
ENVIRONMENTAL DEVASTATION FROM
WILDFIRES AND LANDSLIDES.
IN A NEW ERA OF EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS.
CALIFORNIA IS AN AGRICULTURAL
STATE AND I HAVE A WANT FORM
MYSELF WITH MOUNDS OF
AGRICULTURE WASTE WITHOUT A
PLACE TO GO.
WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
CONVERT AGRICULTURE WASTE INTO
BIOENERGY.
SHOULD BE USING THIS TECHNOLOGY
TO AVOID THE SORT OF OPEN BURNS
WE SAW LAST YEAR THAT FURTHER
POLLUTED OUR AIR. AND WATER
AFTER THE WILDFIRES.
WE FACE THE FUTURE OF RAMPANT
WILD FIRES THAT DEVASTATE OUR
ENVIRONMENT. WATER SUPPLY
CLIMATE GOALS AIR QUALITY AND
ULTIMATELY OUR PUBLIC HEALTH.
NUMEROUS STATE AGENCIES HAVE
WEIGHED IN ON THIS ISSUE MANY
HAVE CONCLUDED THAT BIO ENERGY
IS ONE OF THE BEST AND USES FOR
THE FORCE WASTE TO PREVENT AND
MITIGATE. AGAINST WILDFIRES.
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE MILLION DEAD TREES
AND ARE FORCED DUE TO DROUGHT
AND BARK BEETLE INFESTATIONS.
THESE TREES ARE ESSENTIALLY
HEALING FOR FUTURE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES.
WILDFIRES CANCEL OUT GAINES WE
MAKE THROUGH OUR AGGRESSIVE G.
H. G. AND SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
REDUCTION GOALS.
WE NEED TO AGGRESSIVELY AND
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN TO REVERSE
THIS WILDFIRE SAGA AND THE
STATE'S BIO ENERGY RESOURCES
MUST BE AN ASPECT OF THAT
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION.
I KNOW THAT FOLKS HAVE RAISED
ISSUES ABOUT THE COST OF DEAL
THERMAL AND BIO ENERGY.
BUT VALUING THESE RESOURCES ON A
COST PER MEGAWATT BASES IGNORES
THE HUGE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC VALUES THAT THESE
RESOURCES BRING TO THE STATE.
WE KNOW THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
ONE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES MY
DISTRICT IS IN THE TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WE MUST ACT NOW.
SIMILAR BUT MORE EXPENSIVE BILL
AB NINE TWENTY PASSED OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
TODAY.
FOR GARCIA AND I NEED YOUR
SUPPORT AGAIN ON THIS BILL AB
TWENTY TWO ALL EIGHT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND DIE WITH ME IS WITH RICH
GORDON AND MISTER SEE SEATED THE
AS A TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE.
STILL WORKING ON A JOKE TO
REFLECT ON.
MISTER GORDON THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN CHAIR HOLDEN AND AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS RICH
GORDON. AND I AM THE PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SEEK YOUR
SUPPORT PLATFORM OF FOR A BEAT
TO TO AWAIT. ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCERS.
AGRICULTURAL INTERESTS.
AND THE FORCED INDUSTRY AND
CONSERVATIONISTS.
BIOMASS
GEOTHERMAL AND BIOGAS.
A RELIABLE RENEWABLES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AT ALL TIMES.
SO THEY CAN SERVE AS BASELOAD
AND BALANCING SOURCES OF ENERGY.
IT'S GOOD FOR THE GRID.
IF THE ECONOMY.
GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT THE
STATE SHOULD NOT PICK WINNERS
AND LOSERS IN AN ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS BILL PROVIDES FOR A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
DETAILS TO THAT MUST BE FURTHER
NEGOTIATED.
AND I WANT TO ASSURE YOU.
THAT OUR COALITION IS MORE THAN
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE JOINT AUTHORS.
THIS COMMITTEE.
OTHERS IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
ASSURE A POSITIVE OUTCOME.
I KNOW THAT THIS COMMITTEE
FOCUSES ON ENERGY RELATED
ISSUES.
BUT I WOULD BE REMISS AS
PRESIDENT OF FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION.
IF I DIDN'T MAKE A COMMENT
ON ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERN.
AND THE CONSIDERATION BROADER
POLICY GOALS.
ARE FOREST'S ARE SIMPLY
OVERGROWN.
WHEN THE EUROPEANS ARRIVED IN
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY TREES TO AN
ACRE.
TODAY THEY ARE A MORE THAT
HUNDREDS OF TREES FOR EVERY ACRE
IN OUR FOREST.
HIS OVER GROWTH LEAST TO TREE
MORTALITY.
INCREASED FUEL FOR DEVASTATING
FIRES.
FORCED HEALTH WILL REQUIRE
THINNING OUR FORESTS.
SERIAL LEFT FROM THINNING.
IS BIOMASS.
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW THIS
MATERIAL CAN BE BURNED ON SITE.
RELEASING CARBON AND OTHER
NOXIOUS GASES.
THAT MATERIAL CAN ALSO BE LEFT
IN THE FOREST.
WHERE'D HE REMAINS AS FUEL FOR
FUTURE FIRES.
A THIRD CHOICE.
ETERNITY AND ENERGY.
THE CONVERSATION THIS YEAR AND
THIS CAPITAL ABOUT WILDFIRES
FORCED HEALTH.
CARBON SEQUESTRATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
IT HAVE TO INCLUDE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT BIOMASS.
YOU CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
CONVERSATION BY MOVING THIS
BILL.
WHICH DEALS WITH RELIABLE
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
BY MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO DO
THAT TODAY BY VOTING AYE ON AB
TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT.
THANK YOU.
BUT MR CHAIRMAN PROCESS OR THE
OTHER BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO. HERE PROUD
SUPPORT.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE MOVES
TO HIGHER LEVELS OF RENEWABLES
HAVING A DIVERSE SET OF
RESOURCES WILL BECOME
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT.
AT THIS MOMENT SO LIBERAL TAPE
PHOTOVOLTAIC IS THE LOWEST COST
RESOURCES ACQUIRING FASTBALL
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES MAY BE ABLE
TO BETTER MATCH. CALIFORNIA'S
THAT THE MAN.
MEN SIMPLY ADDING MORE PEAVEY.
AB TWENTY TWO ZERO EIGHT.
PROPERLY PLACES A NEW
REQUIREMENTS ON LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES BASICALLY ALL CUSTOMERS
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
ACHIEVE OVER NOBLE GOALS.
THE ADDED FOCUS ON THE SALTON
SEA IS A STRONG COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL. THE AREA HAS SOME OF
THE BEST YOU'LL FEWER RESOURCES
AS A STATED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA AND THE VELLUM THERE WILL
HELP MITIGATE THE OF OUR MENTAL
IMPACTS OF THE RECEDING SAID
CITY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE GEYSERS.
AS WAS STATED BY ASSEMBLY.
WOMAN.
GEIGER CURRY'S COMMENTS HAS
HIGH WAGE JOBS AND THEY ALSO ARE
IN STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES THAT IS OFTEN
BUILD THEIR PROJECTS WITH
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM AS WELL AS OTHERS IN THE
SALTON SEA AND BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS WORTHWHILE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION TO ACHIEVE
DIVERSITY. AND ACTUALLY HAVE
THAT NEED A A BASE LOW DEMAND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WILL NOW HEAR FROM OF
THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE WHO ARE
HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
OF THE SPELL.
CRAP DAY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIE MALINOWSKI FOLLOW BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE. CBA IS A TRADE
ASSOCIATION STATES WOULD WASTE
POWER PRODUCERS WHO ARE TODAY
TAKING MATERIAL AT THE FIELDS OF
THE FOREST AND DIVERTING IT OUT
A LANDFILLS.
TODAY BECAUSE THE STATE IS
MANDATING THAT THAT HAPPENS SO
AS STATED BY OUR WITNESSES YOU
COULD HAVE THAT MATERIAL TO SIT
THERE AND DO NOTHING OR YOU CAN
DO THE BETTER. THE BETTER
ENVIRONMENTAL CHOICES MOVING
THAT OUT OF THERE IN A
CONTROLLED COMPRESSION
TECHNOLOGY BIOMASS BR IS IS
VALUABLE BEYOND THE RENEWABLE
ELECTRONS AND THIS BILL IS
MAKING THAT POINT THAT YOU HAVE
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFIT. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND FOR THE REMAINING
SPEAKERS NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
I ANSWER OUT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE MADIGAN A BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF LEXICAL WORKERS THAT.
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL.
AS WELL AS THE LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT HAVING LETTER ON FILE
THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
AND MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LOOK AT
FACTS ON BEHALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VINCENT
WERE AT MUCH OF WHAT THE WHITE
MAN GROUP ON BEHALF I TRY POWER
SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
ANASTASIA KOVALCHUK ON THE HALF
OF ENERGY SOURCE IN SUPPORT.
CASSANDRA GOT FUND BEHALF OF
CALPINE LARGE AT THE WORLD'S
LARGEST GEOTHERMAL PRODUCER
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS.
ONE THING WE HAVE EXISTING
FACILITIES IN THE I RP ASSUMES
THEY WILL BE RE CONTRACTED BUT
WITHOUT THIS BILL OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM THEY WILL NOT BE RECON
TRACK.
THANK YOU.
BARBER LA VACHE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN FOR AGRICULTURE
IN THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
LANDOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
KELLY BOY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW CARBON FUEL AND
ENERGY COALITION BROAD COALITION
OF AG INTERESTS FORCED INTERESTS
ENERGY PROVIDERS AND
CONSERVATION GROUPS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
JULIA ELEVEN BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT MORE THAN SEVENTY
PUBLIC AGENCIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES WERE HE TO CONVERT
ORGANIC WASTE TO ENERGY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI JEFFREY HARMON REPRESENTING
HONEY LIKE POWER DOES REVIEW
POWER AND TRACY BIOMASS HOLDINGS
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
DAMN PROMPTLY NO WITH DUNNIGAN
HILLS HAULING SELLING CORTINA
HOLING SHELLING OR TWO LARGE
ALMOND HOLDERS IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE OF THE COMMISSION LARA
KNOWING HE CHECK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT.
GARY CONDIT WITH VIS GRAD ENERGY
SYSTEMS.
WILD CARD OF PROVIDER.
STRONGLY SUPPORT TAKING.
DENNIS ALBION AB HAVE THE ALLMAN
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL BOCA DORO WEST COAST
ADVISERS ON BEHALF OF THE AG
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
BUT DRIVE SOME PRESENT OF THE
WESTERN CULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY TRINA COLORS AND
PROCESSORS IN THE STATE AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KAREN MILLS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS SHOT YOUR AUNTS WE
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON
RESOLVING THOSE CONCERNS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS UNFUNNY ORTEGA
REPRESENTING THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
WHAT OUT YOU AND SALAS ON BEHALF
OF CONTROLLED THEIR MORE
RESOURCE IS ONE OF SEVERAL
DEVELOPERS ITEMS HOMES HE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL?
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH AT THAT
PROCESS BAXTER IMPERIAL COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ON BEHALF
OF THEM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND JUST TO REMIND AND
REITERATE THAT THIS. BILL IS
MORE THAN JUST ENERGY FOR US IT
IS ABOUT IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR OUR RESIDENTS AND
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO DEVELOP A RESOURCE. THAT CAN
LEAD TO HUNDREDS OF GOOD PAYING
JOBS IN A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY WHOSE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES PERSISTENTLY HIGH.
THINKING.
FUTURE MEMBERS CHRIS MCKAY ON
BEHALF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM.
ANY WITNESSES OR INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
THE BILL
.
THIS PROJECT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF TURN.
WE'RE HERE TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO OO
EIGHT I'M WE'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN SEEING EXISTING BIOMASS AND
GEOTHERMAL FACILITIES IN THE
STATE GO OFF LINE. BUT WE ALSO
DON'T WANT TO PAY AND
UNNECESSARY PREMIUM TO GET IN
THE FUTURE WHAT WE'VE
HISTORICALLY ALREADY BEEN
RECEIVING.
AND WE THINK THIS BILL COMES
FROM A PLACE OF GOOD INTENTION
BUT THERE ARE SOME SERIOUS
PROBLEMS WITH THE MECHANICS.
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS BILL WOULD
UNNECESSARILY RAISE THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE RP ES
PROGRAM. FOR RETAIL CONSUMERS
AND WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE OWNERS
OF EXISTING ASSETS THAT QUALIFY
UNDER THE DEFINITIONS OF THIS
BILL. TO EXERCISE MARKET POWER
BY RAISING THEIR PRICES.
DON THAT'S OUR FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERN I'M WE ALSO WOULD NOTE
THAT THE BILL IS STRUCTURED TO
ESSENTIALLY REQUIRE COMPLIANCE
BASED ON TOTAL PROCUREMENT OF A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF MEGAWATT
HOURS.
THE BILL SPEAKS TO THE ISSUE OF
FLEXIBILITY IN GENERATION AND
WANTING TO INCORPORATE
GENERATION THAT CAN RAMP UP OR
DOWN TO MEET SYSTEM LOAD BUT
COMPLIANCE IS MEASURED BASED ON
TOTAL PROCUREMENT AND SO ALL OF
THE ARRANGEMENTS THAT WOULD BE
NEGOTIATED TO MEET THE STANDARDS
AND THIS BILL. WOULD BE DESIGNED
TO FORCE THESE FACILITIES TO
GENERATE THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF
MEGAWATT HOURS NOT TO OPERATE AS
LOAD FOLLOWING FACILITIES. NOT
TO TRY TO INTEGRATE OTHER
RESOURCES
IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY INCONSISTENT
WITH THE IDEA BEHIND THE BILL.
MOREOVER THE DEFINITION OF
ELIGIBLE RESOURCES RAISES THE
POTENTIAL THAT FIRST OF ALL ON
EXISTING SMALL HYDRO ELECTRIC
GENERATION MIGHT QUALIFY AS A
RENEWABLE FLEXIBLE GENERATION
RESOURCE ONE OF THE DEFINITIONS
HERE.
AND IN ADDITION I AM I WOULD
EXPECT
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF COMPLIANCE
OTHER THAN THE SALTON SEA
PORTION TO COME FROM OUT OF
STATE RESOURCES THAT ALREADY
PROVIDE. SOME OF THEIR OUTPUT
CALIFORNIA LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
AND WOULD BE HIGHLY MOTIVATED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF PREMIUM
PRICING.
IT WILL BE AVAILABLE UNDER THIS
BILL FOR EXAMPLE THE PROVINCE OF
BRITISH COLUMBIA HAS OVER NINE
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF EXISTING
BIOMASS
AND THEY ALREADY TRIED TO MARKET
MUCH OF THAT TO CALIFORNIA. SO I
WOULD BE WARY ABOUT THE IDEA
THAT THIS BILL IS NECESSARILY
GOING TO PRESERVE THE EXISTING
BASE OF RESOURCES IN THE STATE
ON THAT THE SPONSORS ARE HOPING.
ON TO PROTECT ON THE BILL AND
THEN FINALLY WHILE WE SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT OF GEOTHERMAL IN THE
SALTON SEA.
THE MECHANISM FOR ACCOMPLISHING
THAT THROUGH THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
ON WORKABLE IT WOULD REQUIRE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY DIFFERENT
BUYERS.
TO OBTAIN FRACTIONAL SHARES IN A
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF NEW
GENERATING FACILITIES THAT WOULD
BE BUILT IN A SPECIFIC
GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
WE THINK THAT IT'S UNWORKABLE AS
DRAFTED ON AND THERE'S NO
MECHANISM TO MAKE THIS WORK IN
ADDITION WE THINK THERE IS
POTENTIALLY DORMANT COMMERCE
CLAUSE VIOLATION AS IDENTIFIED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
I'M WE THINK THERE'S NOT A NEED
FOR AN ALTERNATIVE STRUCTURE AND
MAYBE ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
SOURCES TO MAKE THE SALTON SEA
GEOTHERMAL VISION A REALITY WILL
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THAT. BUT WE DON'T THINK THIS
BILL GETS THERE THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME SHANNON ANY I'M WITH A
LARGE SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION.
ONE ECHO EVERYTHING OF THAT
MATT FRIEDMAN SAID ABOUT THE
BILL I THINK HE HE OCCURRED OUR
CONCERNS ARE WHAT AT A COUPLE OF
OTHERS.
ONE IS THAT YOU KNOW BUT CARVE
OUTS IN THE CONTEXT.
OF THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD ARE DIFFICULT AND THE
MARKET REALLY SHOULD BE THE ONE
DICTATING WHICH ENERGY SOURCES
ARE PROCURED IN WHICH.
WHICH AREN'T SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WERE WERE
DEFINITELY CONCERNED ABOUT WE
ALSO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
PRO KEEP FORCING THE PROCUREMENT
AFFIRMED RESOURCES FOR THE MOST
PART THERE IS A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
CHEER THERMAL AND BIOMASS.
AND RIGHT NOW THE GRID NEEDS
FLEXIBLE RESOURCES MORE THAN IT
NEEDS FROM RESOURCES SO TO FORCE
A TECHNOLOGY INTO THE GRID.
FOR VARIOUS REASONS OTHER THAN
THAT THAT THERE NEEDED TO
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO REVISIT.
MORE BROADLY I THINK THIS THIS
BILL AND I THINK THE ANALYSIS
RAISES THE ISSUE PROCUREMENT
MORE GENERALLY RIGHT NOW
RENEWABLES PROCUREMENT IN THE
STATE HAS SLOWED DOWN.
.
ALMOST TO A FULL STOP WHEN IT
COMES TO THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES THE CCA'S ARE
PROCURING SOME. BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF MARKET UNCERTAINTY AND I
KNOW THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
BILL IS NEEDED TO PROVIDE MARKET
CERTAINTY FOR THESE DEVELOPERS.
I WOULD GO ON TO SAY THAT THIS
THOUGH THAT WHAT WE NEED IS
MARKET CERTAINTY FOR ALL
RENEWABLE DEVELOPERS.
THE PROJECTIONS RIGHT NOW TO
MEET THE STATE'S OUR PS AND
CLIMATE GOALS.
IT WE NEED ABOUT TEN GIGAWATTS
OF NEW RENEWABLE ENERGY LONG
TERM CONTRACTS BUCKET ONE
CONTRACTS.
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THAT'S
PROCUREMENT THAT NEEDS TO START
NOW AND SO I WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN IN A CONVERSATION CERTAINLY
WITH THE AUTHOR IN AND OUT WITH
THE CHAIR ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO
TO. BEGIN OF A SUSTAINED
PROCUREMENT PATHWAY FOR ALL
RENEWABLE RESOURCES BECAUSE WE
DO NEED TO START THE PROCUREMENT
NOW.
AND IT WOULD BE A GOOD
CONVERSATION TO START.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M DANIELLE MALES ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CAUCUS. WE ARE REGRETFULLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND THAT WE
DO SUPPORT A.
AT GOOD DIVERSITY IN THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD AND
CALIFORNIA'S ACHIEVEMENT OF ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS TARGETS AM
UNFORTUNATELY REVIEW THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY A TARGET OUT. GOT
CARVE OUT THAT AT PREAMPS THE
STATEWIDE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING PROCESS WHICH ALSO
IDENTIFIED. ELEVEN HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF WIND.
CURED AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS A
RESULT OF THE.
FADING AVAILABILITY OF THE
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKINGWITH THE
AUTHORS FURTHER IN AND TRYING TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN.
SOME OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
EVERY NOBLE GOALS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND REPAIR INTERESTS
THINKING.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
BUT WE THINK THIS TYPE OF
PROCUREMENT SHOULD BE DONE
THROUGH THE IRP PROCESS WHICH
AGAIN LOOKS AT BOTH GHG GOALS
COST.
AND.
BALANCING THE GREAT WE THINK
THAT'S THE MORE APPROPRIATE
PRICE PLACE FOR THIS THANK YOU.
YEAH AND IF YOU COULD OF NAME.
FILIATION AND.
S. NOT ANYMORE AND ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK
CAPTAIN MY NAME'S YET OF US
ISN'T HE I'M BEHALF A CHALFANT
RUNS JUST ALLIANCE AND ALSO THE
ASIA PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTS
NETWORKING OPPOSE IN THE
POSITION WE SUBMITTED A LETTER
WITH THE CURTAINS.
TRANSMIT ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA.
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED TO THE A BILL AND PRINT
WE UNDERSTAND THERE MAY BE SOME
AMENDMENTS FORTHCOMING IF THAT'S
THE CASE WILL. REEVALUATE OUR
POSITION AND OUR POSITION DOES
NOT REFLECT.
THE VIEW OF ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
THE IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT
WE'VE HEARD FROM PREVIOUSLY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TWENTY
HUNTER WHO BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
AND THE SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT AND.
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR LORDS JIMENEZ HERE
WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
AND FORMALLY.
CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE BEST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HEARING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. AYE BUS.
WE SEND YOU A GUEST IN THAT ONE
YEAR AND IF.
HE'S REALLY AN AWESOME BOSS HE
EARLIER YOU RELEASED SORRY
CAN'T.
SO.
HERE WAS TENURE GAS ELECTRIC IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THE POOR
TO WORKING WITH THAT THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOKERS IN
THE OTHER CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHORED A
STAFF. ARE CONCERNED HAS BEEN
COST IF THIS BILL AS AMENDED AS
PROPOSED COMMITTEE ANALYSIS LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THE JURY MEMBERS RIGHT FOR
ANYWAY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS.
FROM THE AUTHORS OFFICE A BOTH
AUTHORS.
BUT WOULD ALIGN OUR OPPOSITION
WITH THAT THAT IS ALREADY BEEN
STATED REMAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION ON THIS
ITEM I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT KNOW
TOO THAT FIRST OF ALL.
STERN GARCIA WE THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR.
CONTINUED AND AN AUG SO AGO
CURRIES. FOCUSED ON ON THIS
IMPORTANT AREA YOU KNOW I THINK
WE WOULD LOOK TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE TOWARDS A.
BALLOTS A DIVERSIFIED.
RESOURCE PLAN AND SO CERTAINLY.
THESE ARE AREAS BIOMASS AND
GEOTHERMAL THAT WEEK KATIC NOR.
HAVING SAID THAT.
IN YOUR OPENING.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE OPENING
YOURSELF WERE AS I HAVE YOUR
CURRY BUT I THINK YOU.
EXCEPT THAT THE.
AMENDMENTS THE WORD DO EXCEPT
THE A PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE OKAY AND IF I COULD
I'M GONNA. JUST READ WHAT THOSE
REPRESENTED TERMS OF THE AREAS
THAT THEY ADDRESS.
ON PAGE SIX WE WOULD STRIKE
LINES SIX.
TWENTY FOUR.
THAT'S THE FIRST SECOND IS AT
PAGE TEN REPLACE LINES ONE TO
TWENTY THREE.
WEST FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS IN
THEIR LIST OUT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THE STRIKEOUTS.
THEN AND PAGE FIFTEEN REPLACE
LINES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
AND THEN AGAIN THERE'S A LIST
OF.
VARIETY OF ITEMS THAT WE. HAVE
MADE THE CHANGES TO SO THOSE
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE TAKEN.
AT THE NEXT COMMITTEE OF
NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND SO WE ARE IN AGREEMENT ON
THAT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM.
AS FOR THE SO THAT WAS FOR
CLARIFICATION.
SOMERS HERE.
WELL OUR FIRST OF ALL.
I I'D I DO WANNA GO OUT.
SAY THAT I AM SYMPATHETIC WITH
WHAT WERE WERE ATTEMPTING TO DO
HERE.
AND I GUESS THE PART THAT IS ME.
MOST PERSUASIVE.
IS THAT.
THE ABSENCE OF OF REALLY AN
ABILITY.
OUT TO HAVE A CAPACITY TO TAKE
THE THE THE FOREST.
.
I HAD ITS PULL A FEW FUEL AND
THE IT IT'S WAITING TO EXPLODE.
HAVING SAID THAT I AM GOING TO
RESERVE A VOTE NOW.
BECAUSE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE NUMBERS
ARE GOING TO LOOK LIKE THAT COME
OUT OF
THE NEXT GO AROUND SO WE'RE.
APPARENTLY.
IN NATURAL RESOURCES.
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS THAT
BASICALLY DON'T TELL US WHAT ANY
OF THESE NUMBERS ARE.
WHICH MEANS IT'S SORT OF AN OPEN
AN OPEN BOOK HERE.
AND I DO THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
TO HAVE A A LOOK AT WHAT THE
FINAL.
PRODUCT IS GOING TO BE IF IT
HAS.
SIGNIFICANT THE.
RIGHT SPEECH
STRESS IN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
I I LIKE I SAID BEFORE. I'M
WILLING TO CONSIDER.
A A PRICE TAG FOR DOING WHAT
THIS IS PROPOSING TO DO. BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO KNOW THE SCOPE
SIZE AND THE.
THE CONTRIBUTION TO TO SOME OF
THE RATE AT THE ISSUES THAT ARE
OUT THERE. SO I THAT UP I'M
GONNA I'M GONNA LAY OFF ON THIS.
I'M I'M SYMPATHETIC I'D LIKE TO
SEE THE DETAILS.
SO IF I DON'T SEE IT UNTIL THE
FLORA JUST GONNA RESERVE FINAL.
JUDGEMENT UNTIL I SEE AN ENTIRE
PACKAGE WITH ALL OF THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT OF THAT.
INFORMATION THAT THANK YOU.
RESEARCH.
THANK YOU MUCH SHARE IDEA.
YEAH I ALSO I'M NOT SURE WHAT
I'M VOTING ON HERE.
I JUST RECEIVE THE ANALYSIS
YESTERDAY I.
HAVEN'T HAD THEIR.
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL AND
TO.
AYE I'M PREPARED TO GIVE A
COURTESY VOTE PETA.
MY INCLINATION IS TO LAY OFF AT
THIS.
ERIC.
VARIOUS.
THANK YOU.
.
ALTHOUGH I RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO
HAVE.
TO HAVE THIS.
I KNOW THAT ARE IT.
IT DOES POSE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUE FOR SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOW HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THE TRUCKS COMING IN.
.
AND ALL THE DIRTY ENERGY
GENERATED AS A RESULT OF THAT.
.
STE WANTED TO MAKE IT. THAT THAT
IS MIGHT MY BIG ISSUE HERE.
BUT.
SO I SIT SHARE THE VICE CHAIRS
THAT CONCERNED.
ALTHOUGH I'LL BE WILLING TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY JUST THEM
ABOUT I'M I'M BUT MAYBE WE CAN
HAVE SOME EXPLANATION OF WHY WE
DECIDED TO TAKE THESE A MEN'S
TODAY WHY THE PERCENTAGES AREN'T
THERE BECAUSE I DO FEEL LIKE
THAT IS THE ROLE OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO. MOVE
THIS KIND OF POLICY AND IT SEEMS
LIKE NOW WE'RE JUST DIVERTING
THIS AND SAYING HEY WE'RE GONNA
GIVE US NATURAL RESOURCES.
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE BUT TO KILLEEN YOU KNOW
IS THERE ANY AND ALL THAT.
MISS AGAR CURRY IS NOT HERE
DOWN BUT I THINK YOU COULD
PROBABLY TALK ABOUT THIS AND I
KNOW IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY. OF
THIS IS THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT.
IMPORTANT TO US AND SO I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS MOVING ALONG BUT I AND ALSO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO. AYE TO HAVE ITS
SAY.
I I THINK IT'S.
NO I COULD.
CERTAINLY WOULD LOOK TO MISTER
DARCY OF TO HAVE A COMMENT BUT I
THINK IT'S THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION AT
THIS POINT THEY'VE ACCEPTED IT
WAS NOT THEIR INTENT TO HAVE IT.
WITHOUT PERCENTAGES WE WERE
CONCERNED AT THIS STAGE OF
HAVING ANY NUMBERS THAT WE WOULD
BE LOCKED INTO AND WE WERE STILL
WORKING ON.
SOME IDEAS THAT WOULD BE MORE OF
A.
GLOBAL STRATEGY TO ADDRESS.
WHERE THIS MIGHT FIT AND
APPROPRIATELY SO WHERE
ESSENTIALLY MOVING IT FORWARD
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE STILL
WORK AND PROGRESS ON SOME OF
THIS THAT WE NEED TO? CUT A
CIRCLE BACK AROUND AT SOME POINT
AND AN IRON OUT THE DETAILS AND
LOCKING AND TO THE NUMBERS.
TODAY.
HOW MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE AND
DOING THAT RIGHT AT THIS MOMENT?
MR I THINK YOU YOU CHARACTERIZE
IT DOWN THE WELL.
INODE AS LONG AS YOU DON'T CALL
IT HELL MERRY I THINK WHERE I
HAVE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
.
IF IT.
THE FACT IS THAT I THINK AT SOME
POINT RIGHT THERE WILL BE THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
PERCENTAGES.
AND DEBT I THINK THE WORD AND
AND I OFTEN.
STILL THE WORD FROM OUR FORMER
SENATE PRO TEM.
IN IN IT WILL COME BACK WITH
THE THE INTENTIONALITY.
THAT THAT THE DISCUSSION BRINGS
FORWARD TODAY. AND SO I'M YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK.
WITH CHAIR IN HIS COMMITTEE
STAFF OUT THERE IS LIKELY A GOOD
CHANCE THAT THE BILL WILL COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AGAIN IF
IN FACT. I IT IS PREPARED.
TO BE PRESENTED WITH THE
PERCENTAGES AS YOU KNOW US SOME
MEMBER MAYES.
AS IT RELATES TO THE JEWELER
MACUM POINT OF THIS AND I I
THINK THE THE BIOMASS. YOU KNOW
COALITION I WOULD AGREE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CERTAINTY.
WIND THIS UP POLICY COMES TO
THE FINISH LINE.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT IF WE
ARE WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF THE
FIFTY PERCENT ARE PS OR IF THAT
GETS. RAMPED UP THAT THERE IS
CERTAINTY THAT THESE.
FLEXIBLE BY RENEWABLE ENERGIES
WILL BE INTEGRATED INTO THE
OVERALL NOT ENERGY PROCUREMENT
OF.
THE STATE.
WAS ON THE RIGHT TO CONTINUE TO
KEEP WORKING ON THIS THEN THAT'S
GREAT I'M OF THE BILL.
.
WAS ALREADY MOOT BUT WE
APPRECIATE.
IF THIS DOESN'T.
WE WILL.
THERE NO OTHER QUESTIONS UP.
IT'S BURKE.
THAT YOU KNOW AS THAT MEMBER
FROM INGLEWOOD I'M PROBABLY THE
LEAST LIKELY SUPPORTER OF
BIOMASS BUT I'M INCREDIBLY HUGE
SUPPORTER OF BIOMASS I THINK
THAT THERE ARE GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES AND BENEFITS THAT
COME WITH THAT AND AS FAR AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE I
THINK. BIOMASS IS A GREAT
ACTUALLY SOLUTION TO A LOT OF
OUR AIR QUALITY PROBLEMS
WILDFIRES ARE ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE LARGEST GENERATORS OF CICI
SO I THINK WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
THIS WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT IT
IN TOTALITY IN AND. ABOUT NOT
JUST OUR STATE BUT THE COUNTRY
SO. WITH THAT I I'M I'M A CO
AUTHOR FUND IT'S PRETTY.
SCARCE YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK UP THAT THE
COMMITTEE WHETHER BE A COURTESY
VOTE OR A SOLID VOTE TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION ARE.
A WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THOSE WHO HAVE BOMB
OPPOSED.
THE MEASURE TODAY. AND TO AND
KNOW THAT.
MS AT YOUR CURRY'S COMMITTED TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS WELL SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO THIS IS
DUE PASSED IN NATURAL RESOURCES
AND AT THAT POINT THE AUTHOR.
WILL ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AND
NATURAL RESOURCES.
A ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHT DO PASSED IN
THE NAFTA RESOURCES COMMITTEE
HOLDEN AYE AYE HOLDEN AYE
PATTERSON. NOVEL PATTERSON NOT
VOTING.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
GEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GUY EDUARDO GARCIA AYE MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI NOT VOTING QUIRK.
REYES.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
TING.
TING NOT VOTING.
OKAY THAT HAS SEVEN.
WILLOW HOLD THE RULER.
THERE'S NO.
IF YOU.
NTU.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA LOOK FOR A
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO. OUR THE ON
CALL.
OKAY WE HAVE ON CALL TWENTY TO
SEVENTY EIGHT BERMAN.
ROLL CALL ON.
AB TWO TWENTY TO SEVENTY EIGHT
DUE PROCESS A MINUTE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I CALLING
ABSENT MEMBERS CHEN.
CHEN NOT VOTING.
REYES.
THIS IS TWENTY TO SEVENTY EIGHT.
BERMAN.
I.
REYES I.
TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL.
THE BILL IS OUT ON NINE VOTES.
WE'LL DO THE ADAMS.
AB TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT BUT THE
CHAIR MONNING AYE CHEN.
CHEN I.
TING.
OUR TEAM I.
FOURTEEN GOES OUT.
I THINK HOW UNDER TWENTY FIVE
FIFTEEN CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE CHEN.
CHEN I.
QUIRK.
TING ARE.
TING AYE.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
CHEN BY
CHEN AYE QUIRK.
TING.
TING AYE
TO.
ITEM TO AB TWENTY TWO OO EIGHT
WE ARE CURRY.
WE HAVE WE HAVE.
TAKE A MEMBER OR TWO WOULD LIKE
TO REVISIT THEIR VOTE.
AB TWENTY TWO OR A KIND THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
GALLAGHER.
QUIRK.
AND IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
.
IS THERE A CHANGE IN A POSITION
ON.
ON THIS ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY.
THOSE.
BUT GIVE OUR COLLEAGUE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO HER AMENDMENTS
A VOTE CHANGE FOR AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHT REYES CHANGING HER VOTE
FROM NOT VOTING TO AYE.
TING CHANGING TO NOT VOTING TO
AYE.
THAT HAS NINE VOTES THAT BILL
ITSELF.
THEY WILL GO BACK THROUGH THE.
THROUGH THE FILE.
FOR AIDAN'S
.
ADD ONS FOR TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. BUT THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I.
ADD ONS TO TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I
.
ADD ONS TO TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING
.
YEAH I'M JUST.
POLITICALLY FOR THE RECORD.
THAT
.
I'M IS THAT
OKAY A WHOLE VOTES BEEN
REGISTERED THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED